you talked earlier about blake
schneider's save the cat
yeah and you take a lot from his
outlining advice
yeah he had um and i said i said earlier
16 beats it's 15 beats he has the the
main the main
the 15 beats um in his story
um and you know
uh they um you know they
they they pretty much fall in order and
take you through the story
um but they definitely
are i think a great guide and goal posts
to telling you know your story and doing
an effective way
um and um you know they really hit on
again and it goes back to i've said it a
few times working smarter not harder
being able to once you have a clear log
line and you're okay this is the story i
want to tell
it's it's concise and it's just you know
it's 30
to 30 to 40 words um then you start you
want to start breaking it apart and i
feel like
you know it starts with a character and
from there you basically fill in that
character's journey
um you know from um
you know the uh the first part i know
it's always great is he has opening
image
and the opening image is what's the
first thing we say what's the first
thing to remember and i think that's
such a great exercise it's like
how do you want to open the story what
do you want the first thing people see
about your see about your character and
what's it what kind of impact is it
going to have on them
um you know when it goes all the way
through telling it talking about theme
what's the inciting incident
you know the turn the first act turn
the midpoint i will say that i feel like
and he did
mention this is in in his book is that
um
the midpoint is really the backbone of
the story as he said i believe it's
what you hang everything on because the
midpoint
basically is is that center point of the
story
and it does the reversal really of where
that story is going to turn and go often
you know a lot of that uh the reversal
of the carrot for the character really
it's such an imperative
uh beat in the character's journey
our hero's journey uh you know and then
it goes through you know the third act
turn
what's the climax and then finally
what's the last image we see
if you think about and you really apply
that and you again
reference any number of script but
reference the movies
you really get a good sense of you know
seeing you know again
we talked about saving private ryan the
film version you see
the elderly man at the end at the
beginning and then at the end and they
like to have those bookends a lot of
writers like to have
the bookends i sometimes have bookends
and it's you know i think it's it's
great to tie up on
one and then the other i know uh one
film that i loved
uh most recently uh that i've seen in
years or one of the films i loved most
recently
uh was 1917 and it began and ended
the same way and it was you know
obviously just breathtaking
a breathtaking journey that we went on
and um but yeah
they you know again
identifying those beats and having your
character
adhere to it and it doesn't have to be
so rigid i mean again they're
guide posts and they're goal posts and
everyone's is different
um but i know for me that when i do set
out
it helps me really determine where my
character needs to go in the story
do you believe anyone can learn to write
a screenplay that will sell
well there are a ton of factors that go
into that
um you know a lot of your viewers have
probably heard over the years that
you know you don't write what is
fashionable at the moment because then
after you finished writing a script
you could spend six months a year on it
the market's already moved on
um so
i i think again
it goes back to you can write a script
about anything and
the most important thing is that your
readers and you care about the character
or characters you're writing about
because if you're just writing it to the
mark and you're just
writing it to make you know for a big
spec sale which
really don't happen that man that much
anymore they've kind of gone away
um the marketplace has completely
changed
um you know it's
it's one of those things where um
[Music]
i think you again have to write the
story that you feel compelled to
and again if you're not caring about
your characters
you the writer or not your readers and
your audience or not
um it's a i mean it's a tricky question
i think
anyone can write a script that sells
um those factors and then you have to
have somebody
a producer and actor
who are going to really believe in it
you know
the the the business has changed so much
that now it seems you know especially if
you're not going the studio route
you have to get attachments you have to
have actors
you know attached or a director and then
the actor comes in and then you'll
attract financing for it and
and financing at all various levels
um there have been many terrific
screenwriters in in recent years i've
heard about who have written
tremendous spec scripts terrific specs
that haven't sold
um again because the business has
changed so much
what you're seeing you know you know you
can just
you know anyone can go and see what's at
the cinema or what's not at the cinema
right now but what had been pre-coveted
you know it's it's sequels prequels
comic books adaptations there's really
not a whole lot of original material
maybe some horror and comedy
films that are getting through but there
just really isn't
there's a there's a darth of you know
uh creative material that's not
happening and
um i i would just say that
you know you have to write what
is true to you i i also
would say that you know
don't you know um don't write about
yourself that old adage don't write
about yourself just
try to write a compelling story uh tell
a story not your story
um which i think and again i've known
many writers starting out who
wanted to tell their life story and with
all respect
you know unless you're you know some
you've got some really incredible
rich just messed up and there are many
who do
but um you know stick to writing about
what you know
not about yourself per se i think um
and you just never know who's going to
be interested
anything can happen you you may you know
you still may send it into an agency or
for looking for representation they love
it and they go out with it
you could send it to a producer you
could have that actor
friend who knows this well-known actor
established actress
and they get it in their hands and they
love it and they want to do it
i have a friend right now who called up
an old connection who's a
well-known tv actor and he he loved her
script
and he wants to do it he's he's in
um but then it's a matter of getting
other actors attached and
getting actors who are going to get
whoever they're going to bring in and
and um be of value
especially if you're going to pre-sell
the script in the in the states
overseas wherever so there's so many
factors that go into it now
um but i think then it just it does
always boil down to the fact of
and comes back to you know
writing a compelling script but you're
just never gonna gonna know
where it's going to take you or or how
people are gonna react
you